there's a Fox News Alert the Trump
administration just announced the
winners of the hotly anticipated fake
news Awards chief national correspondent
ed Henry's at the White House with the
results on the red carpet hey ed that
sucker good to see you as you know
there's been this anticipation what will
the president do he's been teasing this
out for a couple of weeks now he's now
listed about a dozen fake news stories
in his words that he wants to highlight
we're gonna run through the top five
starting with number five the president
calling out the Washington Post for in
his words falsely reporting a massive
sold-out rally in Pensacola Florida as
being empty he says a dishonest reporter
showed a picture hours before the event
started and it was much much bigger
number four Time magazine falsely
reporting that the president removed a
bust of dr. Martin Luther King jr. from
The Oval Office remember this was
something that time reported literally
day one day two of this administration
it was it was a fake story
number three CNN in the words of the
president falsely reporting the
candidate Donald Trump and his son
Donald Trump jr. had access to hacked
documents from WikiLeaks before the
public did that was not true had to be
retracted as well number two the
president going after ABC News's Brian
Ross in the president's words in this
thing just tweeted out Brian Ross quote
chokes and sends markets in a downward
spiral with false report remember that
was about retired General Michael Flynn
and pleading guilty to that charge of
lying to the FBI Brian Ross suggesting
that this dated back to actual collusion
in the campaign that had to be walked
back that was not true the stock market
crashed on that initial fake news the
president calling that out finally
number one in the president's estimation
for the 2017 fake news awards and I've
been waiting for this Tucker
the New York Times Paul Krugman the
columnist claiming on the day of the
president's historic landslide victory
in the president's words the economy
would never recover as you can see from
the market activity today announcements
like Apple saying they're pouring a lot
more money into this economy bringing
repatriated money back into the United
States that is something that the White
House is crowing about tonight Tucker
Paul Krugman and
and thank you didn't feel great to see
it